se rassembler oui se ressemblent et non
se rassembler pour rire pour échanger
pour travailler oui mais se ressembler
pour est tous pareils
non c'est vrai je reviens de la forêt j
ai travaillé j'ai fait mon métier de
thérapeutes
depuis hier matin jusqu'à ce midi
j'accompagnais des personnes à la
recherche d'une plus grande connaissance
de soi et des autres
nous avons rencontré des arbres je leur
ai fait visiter ou plutôt nous avons
rendu visite à quelques arbres
remarquables et bien vous le savez il y
en a aucun qui est pareil même s'ils
sont de la même famille et vous vous
êtes pareils
je vais vous proposer une petite
expérience
donc si vous voulez bien pour qu'on
puisse nous organiser chacun des rangs
nous allons commencer où vous allez
commencer par raisonner par la droite
durant donc la première personne qui est
à droite durant va se tourner vers la
gauche
la deuxième vers la droite et ainsi de
suite
et vous allez vous retrouver face à face
deux par deux
peut-être
je ne voulais pas dit mais normalement
c'est sans parler
donc vous vous regardez face à face
l'expérience ne veut pas être très
longue à peu près deux minutes
nous démarrons chacun regarde l'autre
personne sans parler sans commenter
juste regarder l'autre et percevoir
l'autre vous regardez son visage
la forme de son visage ses yeux son
regard est peut-être vous percevez ce
que le regard de l'autre vous dit en
même temps que vous percevez le visage
de l'autre vous savez que l'autre puise
perçoit votre visage et votre expression
est votre regard
nous allons suspendre l'expérience et ne
pas la commenter pour l'instant nous ne
sommes pas pareils nous ne sommes pas
des numéros
j'ai 19 ans je rentre dans ma chambre
d'étudiant
je note quelques mots sur mon bureau
et puis je tousse
je tousse je me lève je crache dans le
lavabo blanc du sang rouge rouge puis
noir et du pus qui colle je sais que
demain soir je ne dormirai pas dans ma
chambre d'étudiant genou gauche
enfin je m'allonge je ne dors pas cette
nuit là je mets mes affaires en carton
j'ai écrit quelques mots et le lendemain
matin je vais à l'hôpital toute façon
j'y allais puisque j'étais en stage et
j'apprenais le métier de soigner des
organes des maladies des numéros on
disait l'estomac du 19
la hanche du 24 mai ce petit matin la
fred octobre
je suis allé directement dans le service
de pneumologie
j'ai vu le professeur je suis dit que
j'étais malade
il a fait tous les examens et le soir
j'ai dormi à l'hôpital il m'a dit en fin
d'après midi
écoute yves puisque tu acceptes le
traitement expérimental que tu vas être
le troisième malade français traités de
cette façon je te propose une chambre
seul je savais où étant et les chambres
seules les chambres seules c'est dans le
quartier des mourants et il ajouté mais
tu sais pas ivre tu n'es pas mourant
j'y ai passé six mois dans ma chambre
six mois où la nuit on entend tous et on
entend cracher crier et puis tout à coup
les chariots les infirmières les
médecins le bruit des aspirateurs tous
ces bruits d'urgence est panique que je
connaissais puis plus rien le silence
quelques heures plus tard des voix que
je ne connaissais pas des pas feutrés et
des chuchotements dans le couloir savez
j'ai jamais dormi quand il faisait nuit
jamais d'ailleurs un matin le professeur
de médecine est venu s'asseoir sur le
bord de mon lit il me dit alors yves
comment tu vis ta chambre
ben je dis bien je lui dis je le
remerciais sauf la nuit sauf la nuit
je lui dis le matin quand il le jour se
lève que je m'endors les infirmières
arrive me faire tous les examens il dit
écoute les examens de contrôle toi tu
peux te les faire toi même
c'était là j'ai dit oui il dit écoute
avant de t'endormir tu fais des examens
et puis quand tu voudras ton
petit-déjeuner
tu va sonner il dit d'ici là personne ne
viendra de déranger c'est comme ça que
ça s'est passé j'ai jamais été un numéro
j'ai jamais été une maladie j'ai
toujours été le fils du professeur
d'ailleurs il l'avait dit à mes parents
il avait dit à mon père et ma mère moi
mon fils il est mort à l'âge de votre
d'un accident eh bien je vais soigner
votre fils comme mon fils est ce qui m'a
appris
et je lai a pris dans mon corps ce que
j'avais appris en cours de philo que
l'homme était unique l'unicité de
l'homme et tout ça mais tout d'un coup
c'était dans mon corps et c'est le
professeur qui m'a soigné qui m'a
enseigné l'humanisme
en fait
dans notre société trop souvent nous ne
sommes pas des jeux vieux ni d tu nous
sommes des objets je considère l'autre
non pas comme un tue mais comme un objet
par exemple je m'intéresse à ce que
l'autre pense ce que l'autre dit ce que
l'autre à ce que l'autre fait ou ce
qu'il ne fait pas mais l'autre qui fait
ne fait pas qu'il a ce n'est pas l'autre
ce n'est qu'un objet de l'autre un seul
à une chose en fait ce qui compte c'est
cette curiosité de qui es tu toi toi cet
autre j'aime pas la tolérance
j'aime pas la tolérance tolérée s'est
écarté l'autre parce qu'il ne peut pas
changer ses cartes et ses autres parce
que de toute façon avec ce qu'ils
pensent ils seront toujours pareil
goethe a écrit tolérer c'est aux
français
eh bien je suis d'accord c'est une
offense toléré quand nous quittons cette
curiosité de savoir de conne de
rencontrer l'autre c'est une offense en
fait nous jugeons l'autre et nous les
cartons cette tolérance là c'est une
offense
ce qui compte c'est de se regarder de se
rencontrer de se mettre face à face face
à face deux visages à visage de prendre
le temps de se dévisager le visage quand
l'autre m'offre son visage comme vous
l'avez fait il y à quelques instants
c'est pas une chose c'est pas un objet
l'autre m'offres son visage et il
m'offre un accès immédiat à lui et moi
je m'offre à l'autre ce n'est pas un
masque un visage le visage
il est nu il est dévoilée par la plupart
du temps il est fragile vulnérable
il a des trous trous des yeux trous des
oreilles trop du nez une bouche des eaux
qui ne sont pas collés visage il est
parfois frapper la serre et détruit
mutilés et brûlés mais il est parfois
caressé embrasser embellie
joli vénéré c'est de cette rencontre
deux visages des visages dont je voulais
vous parler et de se rassembler oui pour
ceux des visages et pour savoir qui nous
sommes
pour dire qui nous sommes pour dire quel
jeu je suis et qu'elle tu es tu de
dialoguer et même si nous ne sommes pas
d'accord
soyons d'accord sur le fait que nous ne
sommes pas d'accord et c'est un accord
de ne pas être d'accord mais je vais
vous proposer de clore notre petite
expérience de tout à l'heure donc de
vous remettre face à face sans parler
sans lever les yeux au ciel sans quitter
l'autre et quand vous serez installé je
vais vous donner une petite indication
pour l'instant vous décider qui va
commencer à parler entre vous deux
donc attendez attendez je vais vous dire
quoi dire en fait quand vous allez vous
exprimer vous allez exprimé à l'autre ce
que vous croyez que vos yeux ne lui ont
pas dit dans l'expérience première que
croyez-vous ne pas lui avoir dit avec
les yeux
vous avez 30 secondes pour la première
personne
vous changez la deuxième personne
s'exprime sur ce qu'elle croit ne pas
avoir dit avec ses yeux
j'ai un rêve un rêve que nous
construisions nos sociétés comme une
place de village où nous pourrions
parler simplement dans un dialogue je
tue deux face à face deux visages à
visage et qu'on puisse chaque matin
chaque jour où dans nos réunions de
travail comme nous en a parlé jean
philippe et bien remettre au goût du
jour nos certitudes et remettent notre
histoire au goût du jour parce que
peut-être aujourd'hui quelque chose est
nouveau et en dialoguant belge pourrait
me comprendre moi-même peut-être mieux
et puis si jamais je ne suis pas
d'accord avec l'autre je pense que c'est
très utile de garder en conscience qu'il
est possible que ce soit l'autre qui ai
raison et on se reparleraient demain
matin se rassembler oui
se ressembler
un jour un homme qu'on disait sauvé des
eaux avait entrepris de conduire son
peuple d'un pays à un autre
comme tous les grands voyages comme
toutes les transformations
ça demande du temps quarante ans mais
vous vous imaginez bien que au bout d'un
moment les femmes les enfants et
vieillards et les hommes aussi sont
fatigués donc on arrête on fait une
halte et à ce moment là le chef il est
attiré par le sommet de la montagne et
là bas il rencontre un buisson pas un
téléphone
en fait c'est le visage de celui qu'on
nomme pas de celui qui n'a pas non mais
vous voyez dans l'histoire c'est parce
que moïse rencontre ce visage de celui
qu'on nomme pas qu'il peut redescendre
c'est ça que nous enseigne le mythe
qu'il peut redescendre avec les tables
de la loi qui vont dire comment le
peuple peut fonctionner alors vous
croyez pas vous comme moi que si on
prend le temps de discuter dialoguer
alors on a dit je tue face à face visage
un visage en se remettant en cause en
pensant que l'autre puisse avoir raison
en exprimant de nos désaccords
vous ne pensez pas qu'on pourrait
changer le monde
c'est autre chose qu'être indifférent
c'est vraiment chercher la différence et
vous savez ce qui compte
on dit souvent il faut écouter écouter
écouter c'est pas vrai faut pas écouter
faut entendre
il s'agit pas de regarder
il faut voir l'autre la différence
et puis c'est pas tant une question de
sentir qu une question de raisonner de
raisonner raisonnée
de raisonner à l'autre différent dans ma
différence
et d'affirmer mon jeu résonné dans la